we get it already from the director of
two good Batman movies comes a film that
will obliterate your eardrums with
deafening noses when three thief
Dominik Cobb gets his toughest
assignment yet he'll assemble a team of
experts including this small boy who can
suddenly learn to make complex dream
aces after doodling a chemist who is
literally the worst driver ever
and a sidekick whose only job is to
explain the plot the dream you can cheat
architecture into impossible shapes five
minutes in the real world gives you an
hour in the dream and the dream state
your conscious defenses are lower can't
wake up from within the dream unless you
die raw infinite subconscious nothing is
down there except for whatever might
have been left behind by anyone sharing
the dream who's been trapped there
before and yet even the characters in
the movie can't figure out what's going
on this is my dream why can't I control
it whose subconscious are we going into
itself I'm just trying to understand how
could you understand you don't
understand to get back his children
Cobbs team will have to fight Anonymous
dream soldiers who have no idea how to
hit anything with an automatic weapon or
done a movie so complex it requires
intense concentration at every moment
which is really difficult when this guy
goes over important plot points at a
heavy accent my main competitor is an
old man in poor health it's sound with
so many Herrick control of the
corporation a supposedly original film
that's actually just the meatrix except
with creepier extras and unclear rules
witness Leonardo DiCaprio fight his way
through any physical challenge but
struggled to squeeze through an alleyway
he immerse yourself in the dreams of
Christopher Nolan which apparently don't
include sex flying or any other things
normal people dream of a dream land
where you can think of literally any
weaponry afraid to dream a little bigger
but for some reason only dream up small
to medium sized guns
seriously they couldn't dream up a tank
or something starring Leonardo DiCaprio
Indian Seth Rogen five head the cast of
The Dark Knight Rises George Takei the
son from third Rock from the Sun and a
dreidel inception
if cobb couldn't enter the country
couldn't Michael Caine just fly the kids
out to him whatever thanks for a great
year screen junkies tell us what movie
you want to see is covered in 2013 also
leave a comment below with something
you'd like to hear me say in my amazing
voice your princess is in another castle
it rubs the lotion on its skin or else
it gets the hose again
I dare you I double dare you follow Papa
say what one more damn time
mekka lekka hi mekka hiney ho